[Music]
hello
my name is john tsai it's my pleasure to
have the opportunity
to share my view about impact of kvd-19
on china's healthcare assistance
i'm from the chip academy that's a
non-profit healthcare think tank
i summarizing the china's healthcare
chain post the kohiti 19
into 10 major chance
so first i give you a quick brief
picture about the china's health care
statistics for the china healthcare
expenditure per capita uh in the latest
year
2018 we reach about per person
over 4000 chinese rmb
that's equal to about 600 us dollar
so considering china have a huge
population we have a 1.4 billion
population
so this is the average number
we also see the china health expenditure
as the percentage of gdp
from 2018 it reached to the
6.6 so
that's about average considering the
china's economic status
6.6 in the last 10 years
the increased health expenditures
developed
pretty rapidly in china
also look at the structure of the china
healthcare financing
we have three major sources of the
financing
so the on the top one is the
individual's
personal out-of-pocket payments in the
latest time it's
still about 29
the middle one is represent the uh
social healthcare insurance
expenditure that's over 42 percent
on the bottom one is the government
care expenditure so compared
internationally
we look at the last over 10 years the
personal out-of-pocket payment
gradually reduced however
30 percent compare internationally we
are still relatively
uh to too high so because in the
international experience only the in the
individual out-of-pocket payments
reached to
under 20 percent will significantly
reduce people's affordability problems
okay let's summarizing the
10 future trends of the china health
care system
after coveting 19. the first trend
it's about the public health and the
preventive care
versus medical care
so in the in our memory in my personal
memory because i work in the healthcare
field
about 30 years so in my memory
we always emphasize the chronical care
the importance
the impact on the health care system we
up
for a long time we feel infectious
disease
already long time ago it's already
passed already over so
17 years ago china has the sas
after sas chinese government spent a lot
of money
to build up the labs build up the cdc
system also spend money to have the
the reporting system the infectious
disease reporting system
so however after sas in the last 17
years
in china we haven't had the major
infectious disease we don't have a major
public health
the problems so people in our minds we
don't really pay too much attention
to infectious disease anymore so
in the last 10 years china has the
latest health care reform
after 2209 so
last 10 years governments spend more
money on the medical care
but we really don't pay attention to
public health and preventive care
so this is give us a very important
lessons
we need really after kovidia 19
we need to really increase the
government budget
increased with staff
on the public health and preventing
health the ironical
the problem is if we do better job on
public health and preventive care
we feel that's become less important of
public health
because we don't see the problem right
the medical care is different
you have more people go sick have a
disease
you feel medical care become more
important
after covenant 19 we will believe
the people will pay much more attention
to the public health pay attention to
infectious disease
so the important lessons it's critical
to transfer afterwards high cost
management
into beforehand the low cost prevention
while it is important to put out fire at
all costs
it's even more important to prevent a
disaster from the beginning
right if we do a good job we have a good
public health systems
have a good public preventional care
we reduce the risk to have this kind of
big file
okay so while we have no doubt that
we call the whole nation system can win
the entire covidien 19 war
we hope the public health system can
prevent
an epidemic outbreak coming back
again so because china in this time
in the beginning the early year china in
the wuhan and the hubei
we see the outbreak of the kovidi 19s
we using the china called the
centralized
government using the whole nation system
we
quickly put out files that seems very
successful
but we need to remember we need a good
public health
care system to prevent this kind of fire
happen again
the number two the second trend we
believe
that's the primary and the community
care
will become more important compared to
the tertiary medical care
the china health care system we have the
major problem
we have a tier 3 tier 2 and the
community care tier 1.
for many years chinese people
they skip of the community here skip the
tier 2
they directly go to tier 3 hospital so
in china we call the health care system
is the inverse pyramid ships that mean
the more people
just pulling into the tier 3 hospitals
we will see the data for example in
china we have a 30
000 hospitals ts3 hospital
they only account to about seven
percent of the total 33 hospital
however the tier 3 hospital they account
for
about close to half the outpatient
visits
they account for about 48 of total
inpatient so that's me in china
ts3 hospital they will occupy
about half of the total health care
service
let's look at the last 10-year data ts3
hospital the outpatient visits an
inpatient discharge number the increased
speed
most rapidly more rapidly than tier two
than tier one and the another we call
the undefined hospitals
so that's me in china in the last 10
years
even government said the new health care
reform they want to
increase the people using the primary
care however
we see the last 10 years people still
skip the primary care go to the tier 3
hospital
so this is the problem happened in the
high in the hubei
in the beginning outbreak of the kovidia
19
people don't go to the primary care
hospital directly into a tier 3 hospital
create a problem
cross intersection also create a problem
we called the
health care run up right so
ts3 hospital they are physician
nurse they all become very scared
the resource they also using the old
hospital beds using the
icu resource so this is the problem
that have not happened in many other
countries
even look back many other countries they
have more people
affected so because they do a good job
on the primary care
using the primary care as the first lie
prevention so for example singapore
government
they are using the a 800
primary primary care clinic as a
first first preventive kind of sports
people if you have a problem have some
symptoms you're first
go to the doctor clinic to do a
beginning screening
so in china in the it's happen other
people just pulling into the big
hospital
so create a problem so after covering 19
chinese government in china healthcare
system will pay more attention to
increased primary care for example
in the city i lived in shanghai
create the 200 we call the
fever spots to as the first screening
spots if people have a problem they were
using this kind of spots as the first
check
so we need to
take a lesson to be prevent to have a
i call the inverse reflections because
people maybe will get the wrong
lessons people in china is very easily
thinking because the tier three public
hospital
and the centralized bureaucratic power
we're using that to win the covidien 19
wars
so these forces should be further
strengthened
so i believe that's the wrong lessons
right because we
we locate back we think in the tier 3
hospital they put out the fires
so we need to further need to
consolidate we build up more tier 3
hospitals
so on the test opposite we need to
really increase the preventive care
to using the preventive care to provide
these kind of first-hand screening spots
so the number three
so i summarize the number three trends
to offline versus
online versus offline so during the
outbreak of the covidien 19 because a
lot of hospital class
close the service they don't take in
don't accept the regular patients
so people have to use the internet-based
medical care
have to use the record internet
hospitals
to get consulting to meet a doctor
online
so during last six months
in china also internet-based pharmacy
start to be highly developed also
government
social insurance starts to allow people
if you receive the medical care online
receive the pharmacy online
they start to reimbursement this kind of
online service
before covering knighting outbreak so
health
government insurance don't allow do this
kind of reimbursement
so during the last six months china
the online service start to be booming
i believe that's happened in many other
countries that's like we have the online
conference online working
online education i believe after covida
19 this kind of online medical care
will become relatively more important
people in china a lot of hospitals start
to build up what we call the internet
based
hospitals so this is very important
trend we need to pay attention to using
more unless service
the number four trend is summarizing
it's called outpatient versus inpatient
it's like we see because of the close to
hospital
during the outbreak of video 19 people
have to using the art of hospital
service
we using the community care home care
day surgery third party independent
service
it's like independent third party
screening
third party imaging third party lab so
this kind of a service
also after covida 19 i believe this kind
of way
we will see the trend people develop
more out of hospital service we could
in the reality we see a lot of service
we don't have to be
provided inside the hospital so this is
the
china health care system tend to highly
rely on the hospital
to provide all different kind of service
we see many many countries
have a more developed independent third
party service
also have a more clinical care
so in china we believe
after the coveted 19 this kind of
outpatient
move out of hospital will become an
important chance
so for for our company we the future
we're doing the business we should pay
attention to this chair
maybe we should we'll deal with
more this kind of hospital service
also number five future chance i call
the diagnosis versus a treatment
during the period covida 19 we see
diagnosis become a very
important tool because
only if we have a correct diagnosis
we are going where we could
fight this kind of infection as soon as
possible
so during the last six months we see a
lot of ivd
business become highly developed
so diagnosis company if they have a
diagnostic business
they are have a see a huge increase
in the last six months so even
we see the kovidia 19 maybe
people most people believe we have
become a long-term kind of work who
exists
with us more than probably one year so
we believe
diagnosis business will become more and
more important
compared to the treatment
the number six trends we see that i call
the
traditional chinese medicine versus
western medicines in china
in the hubei during outbreak
we see that in chinese healthcare system
we see we're using the tcm
to apply to the patient almost all
patients
except for the most serious patient
people if you icu
we probably don't need a tcm however in
china
we apply the tcm to about to the 90
percent patient
we also see they do have some kind of
impact to reduce some kind of symptom to
really help
cavity 19 affect patients to help them
to recovery
better than the people without the tcm
so in china we see the government
also we see the people start to
really use the tcm more and more also we
also
see some kind of international
multinational fakmase company
in china they start to interested in the
chinese medicine we see a few companies
they do that also
the number seven trend which i call the
software versus hardware
the software i mean it's more on the hr
people's staff medical resource human
resource also
information technology
in china we have the long time tradition
people government really pay attention
to that i call the hardware
how do i mean that we put a lot of money
on the
building right on the on the
medical device on the labs on this kind
of things
concrete we could see but we don't pay
much attention to the soft things to the
people
so in china in the long time we have the
problem
we spend two less money on the people
spend too much money on the
infrastructures
probably because of the terms of the
government employee
the terms of the hospital management
they have a four years trend
during the full year it's very easily to
if they spend money on the hardware they
will see
their performance if they spend money on
the people
you know very easily to see the outcome
in such kind of short time so in china
the healthcare professional is a serious
problem
let's see some statistics here i select
10 countries with the most population in
the world
we compare to the physician and the
population ratio
look at this number china just happened
in the middle of this 10 country
we have the physician compared to 10 000
population
locate this number with less compared to
russia and the u.s
however compared to the india another
developing country
our chinese number will be more than
double than the india so look at this
number seems
okay china we have a less physician
than country and more physician than the
other
country however let's look at a
background education background about
the chinese
physicians china have about over
three million physicians we see only
a little bit over half of the chinese
physician they receive the education
four-year college and above we still
have
over a million physician they received a
two-year college
vocational school high school even under
so compared to the india all the
physician they received
higher education so that's me that in
china
the education background of the doctors
it's
not very qualified so this is the
problem why chinese people they skipped
community care even the tier 2 hospital
did directly go to the tier 3 hospital
because people don't trust a physician
there so this is a problem
for china we need increased
more edu qualified the more educated
doctors
okay however we look at
another number it's ironically
we have a huge shortage of qualified
doctor in china
but on the other hand we look at the
last 40 years we see
every 10 year for period we see compared
to
the first column the second column is
the
medical school graduates
within the 10 year okay we look at the
fourth period the recent ten year we see
we have a
six million graduates from medical
school
however during the 10 year we see
another colon
that's the increased physician during
the same period
increased physician only 1.4 million
right the ratio is the 4.5 million so we
have a more supply
physician we have a less increased
physician
so that's me a lot of qualified
received medical school graduates
they didn't go to become a clinical
doctors
they switched the job they give up to be
the doctors
so we see this is a huge problem in
china
on the one hand we have a huge shortage
of the qualified doctor
on the other hand we have
medical school graduates they don't want
to be the clinical doctors
so this the problem that's indicated in
china
we spend not enough money we don't pay
reasonable payment to the doctors
so doctors become not very attractive
jobs in china
right so that's me so after
the coveted 19 this important lesson
we need a more educated doctor we need a
qualified doctor
qualified a nurse qualified icu
professionals qualified ed doctors
so we need to spend more money on the
medical staff
more money on the public health staffs
so let's look at the number eight trend
i call the private
and public health care in china
let's look at the number in china we
have a total
33 000 hospital in total
private hospital right now increased
very rapidly in the last 10 years
so we told the hospital a month total
hospital about two
search they belong to the private
hospital
public hospital only about a little bit
over one third
however this hospital number
it's not a whole picture let's look at
the bets
look at our patient visits locate the
inpatient stay
public hospital account to about 80
percent
so that's me private hospital even they
have a more number hospital
it's a private hospital however they
occupied
only about 20 percent of the health care
service in china
within the last six months we see the
when we're
fighting kv-19 chinese using the public
hostel
as a major forces so people will tend to
get a conclusion they feel private
hospital it's not important in china
because it
doesn't really play some kind of role in
fighting kvd-19
however i'm thinking this also provide a
case sets
inverse reflection because in china we
still a lot of policy
to not favor private sectors they don't
really compete
fairly with public hospital under a lot
of policy for example
the insurance coverage they have a lot
of government research money
they don't cannot compete with public
hospital to attract
good doctors so that doesn't mean
private hospital is not
important we need to still play a more
fair room
to allow private sector to have a more
uh more room to develop so in the future
when we're
fighting with kovind 19 i believe if we
have a good policies
private hospital they should play a more
important role than
right now situations
number nine nitran i called it's the
consumption medicine versus
serious medicine serious medicine that's
recorded that's more traditional we we
call the
the we're using the doctors provided the
serious medicine in the hospitals
consumption medicine
small reflect some kind of consumption
goods they have a consumption goods
feature
they also have a medical features they
tend to represent some kind of
preventive care
some cut for example nutrition some kind
of a counseling medicine
health management because during the
cavity 19
people start to pay more and more
attention to preventive care
prevent to pay attention to for example
facial masks
we have this kind of cleaning
cleaning the waters all these kind of
things so
after covering 19 this kind of we call
the consumption medicine
they will become much more important
when if the company
they have this kind of business they
provide a nutrition
provider preventive the the medical
goods
they will become more important
so the number 10 we call the peacetime
versus
water that's me the strategic
medical supply system and the logistics
so this is a very important license we
got
not only for china probably for our
country
we don't have a good prepare for example
give
example in shanghai we have
more than 20 million population that's a
huge city
during the outbreak of the covedo 90 in
shanghai
the total storage of the facial marks in
at that time it's only 300 thousands
however in shanghai we have about 300
medical staffs
so that's me the storage official mask
only could use the
one mask for one
medical staff used one time however at
that time
hong kong government have a storage a
facial mask
in shanghai it's called they have
have a 5 50 million
facial marks they have a storage in sha
heights okay
so after convenience 19 the government
pay a lot of attention
they need to prepare this kind of a
medical supply
including the facial masks and this kind
of cleaning medicine
nutrition pharmacy some kind of lab
tests device all these kind of things
become very important
and the logistic information systems
so we need to have a better preparation
for prepared because kovidi 19 probably
will coexist
for us for a long time so we need to do
a better
preparations okay let's
make a final summarize it's in
it's very important to make
organizational and the systematical
change
and improvement to reduce and avoid the
consequence and impact of kvd-19s
we need to make a systematic changes
not only just change the world peace
we need a whole nation we need to do a
better preparation
to prepare for the future infectious
disease come back again
also we need a whole health care system
to make better preparation to make
better changes after epidemic
people and the government will pay more
attention to overall population health
and the healthcare sectors healthcare
will become a more important sector
in the national economy so because
people
will have a high conscience
about their personal health about their
family health
for the government we appear a lot of
tension will spend more money on the
health care sector
so for us for people we work in the
health care sector we are very
fortunately
right because many many industries after
covering 18
they'll be affected seriously their
growth rate
will be reduced even become negative
however for
[ __ ] myself for the medical health
industry we still see the booming we see
a lot of
opportunities so we need to really make
a good preparation
to to help the healthcare system
to do a better job thank you very much
you